[Music]
first time i saw poker game was in a
barber shop when i was eight years old
you know i asked my grandfather i said
what were they doing he said they were
playing poker
i was hooked ever since ivy shoves the
river
got a trick or two up his sleeve very
intimidating glare and a little smurf
welcome
to ivy's world you'd just love to
get inside his head for five minutes
paul jackson has a very famous hand in
poker
i had queen eight he had five six and
the flop was jack jack seven
i bet he raised me i re-raised him both
guys
with nothing key point was when i asked
him
how much chips he had three sixty the
way he answered it
made me pretty confident he didn't have
anything all in
what it's mind-blowing what we just
witnessed from phil ivey
[Music]
i come from a generation with a good
players new talking about a hand
or helping someone to improve was a big
no-no
but maybe it's time that i share my keys
for success
i'm phil ivey and this is my master
class
[Music]
you